Good afternoon and welcome
to toxic Google. Today we're
joined by Arlene bloom,
celebrated alpinists in biophysical
chemist as a mountaineer.
She lived the first all
female ascent of Annapurna,
one of the 14 8,000 meter peaks on Denali.
She Co led the first women's team climb.
She was the first American woman to
attempt Mount Everest and completed the
Great Himalaya traverse across Butan,
Nepal and India.
As a scientist, she's worked as a
tireless advocate for consumer safety.
Her research has focused on the use of
toxic chemicals in everyday products.
This work has led to bands
and carcinogenic flame
retardants and children's
sleepwear and household furniture.
Currently she serves as executive director
of the Green Science Policy Institute
and as a visiting scholar at UC
Berkeley's department of chemistry today,
she will share stories of climbing and
policy from her memoir breaking trail,
uh, climbers climbing life. Please
join me in welcoming Arlene bloom.
Well,
it's really great to be here sharing
adventures in both science and mountain
climbing because I suspect many of you
have your own adventures and things
relating to science and it probably
feels like mountain climbing. Um,
so I'm going to send, some of you might
be looking at me and thinking, you know,
that I seem like a regular person,
and how did I start doing
all those crazy things?
So I will start back where it all started.
That's my freshmen chemistry
lab at Reed College.
And my chemistry professor
was a young woman.
She was 23.
She had a phd from Mit and thought
chemistry was the neatest subject on the
planet. There were four girls in my class,
and we all got doctorates in chemistry,
which says something about the
importance of role models. Um, also,
my chemistry lab partner was
a very handsome young man, uh,
from Portland who was a mountain climber
and late one starry night, he said,
do you want to go climb Mount Hood? And
he was very handsome, so I said, sure.
And we drove up to timberline lodge
and he put a big pack on my back.
I was from Chicago. I had never done
anything very physical in my life.
I started gasping.
He later said he didn't think I'd
make it out of the parking lot,
but he was very handsome.
I was very determined and
we got up on the snow.
It was the most beautiful place I'd been.
I fell in love with him and with
mountain climbing and started a life of
mountains and molecules, or we said
peaks, public policy and public health.
So I continued doing expeditions.
Um,
back in those days,
the world's highest mountains had
not been climbed much by women.
And indeed when I applied to
go on an expedition to Denali,
the highest mountain in North America,
I was told that women didn't have the
physical strength or emotional stability
to climb mountains like Denali.
So this is the first all women's
expedition on top of Denali,
which I took the picture so I'm not in it.
Um,
and so I continue doing mountains and
molecules and then things really changed
on this beautiful mountain in India. Now
isn't, this isn't a stock like a easy,
beautiful mountain. When do you all like
to be there? It's nearly 24,000 feet,
but it's general snow slopes and
reclining this mountain and got,
um, up to near the top. It was our summit
day and I'm kind of a slow climber.
So the others got to the top first.
And when I got to the top,
someone said what happened to
Bruce who had gotten there first?
And Bruce had walked along
here to what was here,
which was snow,
but it was actually a cornice or the
snow is over a rock face and the cornice
broke and he fell to his dad.
And Bruce was the country's
leading young rock climber.
He had pioneered the hardest droughts
in Yosemite without using p tons.
And it was just unbelievable that he
died on this easy but high mountain in
India. So when that happened, I
got very depressed at the time.
I was a postdoc at Stanford studying
how proteins fold and that seemed really
irrelevant and I wanted to do something
for the environment in Bruce's memory.
And so I went to a professor of Mine
at Berkeley, but I, my Earth Committee,
Bruce Ames and said, is there anything
I can do to help the environment?
And he said,
well,
why don't you look at the flame retardants
in children's sleepwear? He said,
right now,
pretty much all the kids in America are
wearing pajamas that are 10% by weight
of flame retardant called brominated Tris.
And I think it might get from
the pajamas into the children.
And it's a cancer causing chemical,
I think.
And so it seemed a little weird to me,
flame retardants.
But I was depressed and I
thought I want to do something.
So I found a little girl who'd never
worn interest treated pajamas and we put
her in the pajamas and
collected her urine. And the
first morning she wore them,
she had tris breakdown products in her
urine and she wore them for three days.
The level of Tris in her urine went up
and she stopped wearing them and it went
down. So it meant the truss was
getting into the little girl.
And then we ran a screening test
to see if Tris was a Mutagen,
did it change DNA? And it was one of
the strongest mutagens ever studied.
So this was a huge worry and we thought,
oh my goodness,
we need to tell the parents of America
that most of the kids in the country are
wearing pajamas that are 10% by weight,
this harmful chemical.
So about that time I got invited to go
to this mountain. Do you know what Matt?
And this is,
anybody know
not Everest. It's the highest mountain
in the world. And at that point,
no American woman had ever even had a
chance to try to climb Mount Everest.
So I was like, wow, this is such an
opportunity and I didn't know what to do.
Should I stay and write the paper about
the Tris treated pajamas or should I go
try to climb Mount Everest?
So I can't help but ask,
how many of you would have stayed and
written the paper about the tryst cheated
pajamas? Most of you, how many of
you would've gone to Mount Everest?
Ah, even more. Well, I did both.
So I did go to Mount Everest and when I
was climbing in the Khumbu icefall every
night I write the paper.
And then up in the great western coon
cow, we put stringing
ladders and making her way.
It's the crevices and we
get up steep ice faces.
And every night I keep working on the
paper until I reached my high point.
Here I am at about 24,
five on Everest.
And my summit flag,
um,
the mutants has a petri dish without Tris.
There only two colonies cause it's a
Mutagen. And this one you can't see,
it's blowing in the wind.
That's the Tris Petri dish
with many bacterial colonies.
So this was on October of 1976
and we did reach the summit.
We were the second American expedition.
Now people reach the summit all the time.
But the first American expedition was 63
and we were the second one in 76 so it
was much less, and we had the
whole mountain to ourselves.
Only one expedition on Mount Everest,
which is a little bit different nowadays.
So I finished the paper,
I sent it by mail runner to Katmandu and
it was published in science magazine a
couple months later. And if you
read the subtitle of the paper, um,
the main flame retardant in children's
pajamas is a Mutagen and should not be
used. Now that's a little bit
of an unusual title for a paper.
If any of you, I'm sure you have,
if you read scientific papers,
they tend to have the same recommendation
at the end almost invariably.
And what's that recommendation at
the end of all scientific papers?
What is the next step?
More studies.
And it's always more studies and it
tends not to be something like a chemical
should not be used in kids pajamas.
And at the Green Science Posey Institute,
our goal is to really help inspire,
encourage scientist to take their
research and tell people what needs to be
done. Because scientists are
the ones who really know,
they understand the science and then
they understand what needs to be done.
And we believe that that science is to
have a responsibility to share their
science in a way that affects change,
particularly if they're working on
harmful chemicals. So, and it works.
Scientists are very respected
when they speak up. Things happen.
This was January of 1977,
uh,
where we called for tourists
not being used in kids pajamas.
And April, 1977 Tris was banned from
kids pajamas just like it should be.
And that was a really good thing because
whole generations of kids only wore it.
It was only used for a couple of years,
which is a very good thing. So however,
when a chemical is banned,
there's a big tendency to replace it
with another chemical that's very similar
because industry likes to keep processes
as similar as possible. It makes sense.
Um, and if it was funny, I remember
about six months after the Tris ban,
I thought, I wonder what they're using
now, if they're still using tourists.
So I remember I rode my bicycle to
penny's downtown Berkeley and I bought 20
pairs of pajamas and all different sizes.
And the sales lady just gushed to me,
Oh,
you have such a nice big family.
And I sort of felt like a super spy with
all my pajamas. And I thought, well,
these might make nice shower
presence for my friends.
So I just took a little fabric
out of the inseam of each Pajama.
But I actually didn't need to
bother since none of them would.
I have wanted to give for presence.
And then I analyzed what was in them.
And not surprisingly about a third of
them had brominated Tris, you know,
cause it takes time for
the market to turn over.
But then nearly two thirds
of them had a new chemical,
which turned out to be
chlorinated Tris almost identical.
And so we went,
oh my God.
So we ran more immunogenicity tests
and chlorinated Tris also as a Mutagen,
it changed DNA.
And uh,
we at another paper in science and
chlorinated Tris was removed from pajamas.
However,
what we didn't know then as it
continued to be used, for example,
in furniture,
and in 2005 when a very bad flame
retardant was banned from use in our
furniture,
it was replaced with coordinated Tris,
which was then band in 2012 but if any
of you have a couch that was purchased
between 2006 in 2012 anyone have a
couch sleep purchased during that time
anyway, there's about a three
quarter chance that your couch,
5% of the weight of the foam
will be chlorinated Tris.
So if you have 20 pounds
of foam in your catch,
you have about a pound of this chemical
in, in your couch. Not the best,
but we didn't know it back then.
And back then I thought it was really
time to give women a chance to climb one
of the world's highest mountains.
So, um, in the 70s, all the roads,
8,000 meter peaks,
there are 14 of them.
The highest mountains in the world had
been climbed by men and no women had
climbed that high. And I thought
women should have a chance. Um,
we've done pretty well on Everest,
so I got a permit for Annapurna on my
way back from Everest and I thought it's
the lowest of the apple.
It starts the first of the 8,000 meter
peaks ever climbed among the lowest,
it must be one of the safest and easiest,
but as it turned out,
there wasn't so much
research in those days.
So guess which is the most dangerous of
all the 8,000 meter peaks Annapurna and
which has the highest,
the highest fatality rate
and is considered perhaps
the most difficult to climb.
Anyway, we didn't know
that, uh, but we found out,
so this is our team. Uh, we had 10
climbers, a couple of filmmakers,
base camp manager, we're
all still friends. Um,
there are copies here afterwards.
I'm happy to sign copies of Annapurna
or breaking trail for people.
And Anaplan has just been reprinted.
Um,
like September 15th,
a CRQ books had been out of business
and the book had been out of press for a
few years.
So it's just back in past and we're
all going to be getting together for an
print, a book party next month. And
I have to say when we get together,
it feels like we're back on the glacier
and just like it did in a long time ago.
So climbing Annapurna
was incredibly beautiful.
I'll just share a few of the pictures
place that the beauty was extraordinary,
but the king was really tough
and there were huge storms.
The reset,
it's such a dangerous mountain is very
high precipitation and these huge snow
falls lead to huge avalanches.
Uh,
so it was a very dangerous
place ever since I became a mom.
I haven't wanted to go there.
Um, but wonderful climbing.
And we did reach the summit. We were
the first women, the first Americans.
We reached the summit
with two sherpa climbers.
We unfurled are flags,
um,
held together with the save the whales
pen and we felt content that we have
achieved our goal,
but we tragically lost two of our
team on a second summit attempt.
So climbing an opponent, it's a
very, very dangerous thing. Um, I,
I wrote this book and a Pronoun, a
woman's place, which now as I said,
it's just been reissued this week.
Um,
and then I wrote another
book breaking trail.
I'm trying to understand how my
childhood and my life had led to both my
scientific research and my,
and my mountain climbing.
And when I finished breaking trail,
it was in 2006.
Um,
I'd spent 20 years writing breaking trail.
It was like a personal therapy project.
It was a lot of work trying to understand
my family and I just finished the book.
My daughter was starting,
I thought I really would like
to go back to doing science,
but I hadn't,
I actually stopped being a scientist in
1980 to walk across the whole Himalayan
mountain range.
I had a job at UC Berkeley and I said,
I want to take a year off to walk
across the Himalayas. And they're like,
we have to decide you want your
chemistry job or the Himalayas.
So I chose the Himalayas in 1980 and um,
many things intervened. It
was 2006 26 years later. And,
um, when the last sentence of
breaking trail, it is the sun.
Um,
the future is like an unbroken snow slope.
I hope I can find a way to
break trail to a better world,
but I actually really didn't know what
I was going to do because if you haven't
done science for 26
years, I thought, well,
maybe like you had a job washing
test students in the lab. You know,
I thought I must be
completely out of date,
but that was nine years ago and the
last nine years I have felt every day.
Like I was climbing Annapurna like I
been on my life's greatest adventure and
it's been really similar because we're
working with a great team of scientists
and business people all over the world.
A bunch of people in Google
or on the same team, um,
really working together for healthier
and safer products. And, uh,
it's a, it's a real challenge,
but you know, a real opportunity.
So I felt incredibly lucky that I could
not do science for 26 years and then
come back and be able to, to, um,
really try to climb this mountain.
And the reason that we're all climbing
this mountain is there is a big problem
and that is, I sometimes ask this
question, I bet you'll know the answer,
but what do you think?
Do you think if you have chemicals in
your shampoo or your toothpaste or your
chair, anyone thinks the government
is making sure they're safe for their,
your health? You all know not,
but most people do think that.
I used to think that and the government
actually can't because they don't have
the authority.
There's only one law about chemicals
before they go out in the world.
Once they're out in the world, you have
a clean air act, the clean water act,
but you can't really bring them back in.
So they only law before they go out in
the world is called the toxic substances
control act.
It passed in (970) 660-2000 chemicals
were grandfathered like you're okay and
even a chemical,
I guess bestest that kills 10,000 people
a year cannot be controlled by the EPA
and you might say as best as there, as
best as law suits, asbestos is illegal.
Well as best as is not illegal,
there are lawsuits and there's a rare
form of cancer called Mesothelioma that's
only associated with this Bestus exposure.
So if you're an asbestos worker or the
specify in his bestest worker and you get
Mesothelioma,
um,
you can sue the asbestos industry that
that's the reason for your disease and
you'll probably win the case,
but you also will die.
Everybody who gets Mesothelioma dies
and that's not a good way to regulate
chemicals. And that's how we regulate
a stasis through lawsuits. By then,
it's really late.
So the 62,000 chemicals,
nobody can do anything about.
There've been 20,000 new
industrial chemicals.
No data is required.
Most of them have no health data.
Two thirds have no data at all.
The EPA has six weeks to try
to show harm with no data.
And if they do show harm,
the company has several years to
try to prove their chemicals. Okay.
And they can sell it during those
several years to raise the money for the
testing. And once they're out there
selling it, it's really hard to stop it.
So basically, and indeed, I'm going
to speak at the EPA tomorrow. In fact,
if anyone, anybody wants to hear my talk,
you can tell them 10 o'clock tomorrow,
I'll be speaking by the post
office, the main EPA building. Um,
ask the EPA, they say we can't even Banis
best us. I mean, they say that it's,
it's really a problem.
Another problem. And in fact,
the fact this leads to what
two brilliant pediatricians,
herb Needleman and Phil Landrigan said
that we are defacto conducting a human
toxicological trial,
um,
our children and our children's
children's or the experimental subjects.
So if these chemicals aren't
tested, uh, in any other way,
they're tested on us and
that's not a good thing to do.
And they do contribute to increased
rates of cancer, infertility,
neurological impairments.
So another problem is what we call
the regrettable substitution problem.
If after a lot of work,
a chemical is regulated,
the substitute is often the
chemical cousin. For example,
over here we have, you know,
chemistry. We've got Deka,
Bromo 10 bromines die fennel to fennel
rings that could brominated diphenyl
ethers. That's an ether bond
with the oxygen in the middle,
and it's persistent,
bioaccumulative and toxic.
So after many years,
and it's about 15% of the weight of
the plastic and an average TV is deck
Abramo. Dot. Fennel ether, um,
it's used in fabric, back codings,
many uses,
um,
due to its severe persistence,
bioaccumulation and toxicity.
The decade ether has been phased out,
but what's the substitute?
Deca brominated dive fennel ethane.
So there's an ethane bond instead of an,
it's also persistent biocumulative
and appears to be toxic.
So as the decade ether sales go down,
the decade ethane sales go up,
is that a good deal?
Not much improvement. So it's a
discouraging situation, however,
everyone's looking depressed but me,
right?
Because I think there are
things that can be done. And,
um,
to solve this problem,
we decided to bring together scientists
who cared passionately about this to
really focus on what could be done.
And so we have had a series of retreats,
uh, where we invite five
scientists from industry,
five from academia, five from
Ngos, and five from government.
So it's about 20 scientists,
maybe 25.
And at the first retreat we said,
are there certain chemicals,
certain chemical families
that we know are harmful,
that can be avoided? A simpler
way of thinking of this? You know,
when you think of that 80,000 chemicals,
it sounds kind of daunting. Like, oh,
you can just kind of put your head down
and get poisoned because who can deal
with 80,000 chemicals?
So we came up with six classes and
this is a solution that really invites
action.
And so briefly,
the classes are highly
fluorinated chemicals.
These are standing water repellent
like Scotchgard. Let me just ask,
how many of you knew or know,
and by the way,
there's a handout at the back when you
leave that lists all the classes and more
information about them.
But let me say,
how many of you know that Scotch
Guard is a problem in these chemicals?
Okay. One person who
works in this area, um,
but when people know they
can make better choices,
the next class is the
chlorinated antimicrobials,
like Tyco San and triclocarbans and
liquid soaps. Who knew about them?
A couple of people.
Then we have the flame retardants.
Who's heard about the flame returns?
Okay,
you've all heard about the point
returns. Uh, we have this fantasy.
Remember those bits? Funnily water
bottles, ballet, it's organic solvents,
certain metals.
And you look at this list,
this is most of the harmful
chemicals in everyday products.
And when you know they're there
and you know what they are,
you can make safe choices
and avoid their use.
And even more than that,
we want to ask if they're in that class.
Is this chemical really necessary?
So if the chemical that makes a carpet
standard palette is a highly fluorinated
chemical that's quite toxic and
never breaks down for geologic time,
maybe if you'd say to a mom,
you can have a stain repellent carpet,
but the chemicals going
into your baby's body.
And what would the mom say? Maybe
she might say, it's not worth it.
It's not worth it. Um, so I believe
just asking these questions,
do we really need it?
Is it necessary?
You can stop the use of a big chunk of
these chemicals really reduced their use.
And then if you think they're
necessary and they're worth it,
then say is there a safer alternative
and really invest in that safer
alternatives. So we've heard about
green chemistry for a very long time.
It's been around for 20 years.
A caustic book was written by John Warner,
who's here in Boston and I'm Paula
Nastiness. Um, and it's a great idea.
Everybody loves it, but it's not
happening as much as it should.
And so if a kind of function is needed
and you really want that function,
then invest in green chemistry,
not in moving to the chemical cousin.
Um, we have a webinar series about these
six classes. They're 15 minute webinars.
There's a flyer in the back. And uh,
when we played the Webinar series,
when we ran them live,
about 1200 people signed up and they
were for many of the retailers and
manufacturers across the country.
And amazing things happen.
Like there was a Webinar on
antimicrobials and after it was on,
someone from target called and said,
we had no idea that we had [inaudible]
sand in our personal Caroline and we're
taking it out.
And they just took it out like right away.
So companies can do that overnight.
For government, it's much, much harder.
So if you want to learn more, you can
listen to this webinar series. Um,
purchasers are key manufacturers
of consumer products can
just stop using toxics
in their products.
And that is starting to happen.
Large retailers can say we're not going
to sell a Kia is our leading example.
A Kia has it said no more
fluorinated chemicals.
Almost all of the six classes a Kia is
not putting in any of their products,
which is really inspiring.
And then corporate big buyers can say,
we're not going to purchase products with
these harmful classes of chemicals and
consumers. Consumers is a hard group
to reach. They get many messages.
They're pretty busy.
Uh,
so we prefer to work with some of the
larger purchasers and manufacturers.
Um, and the actions for manufacturers
is to come together and say,
we want disclosure,
we want to know what's in our products.
And then we want to really ask if
harmful chemicals are needed and ask for
products without them. And if that's
not possible, invest in Green Chemistry.
So a very cool thing is there's a buyer's
club out in California and Google is a
number along with Kaiser and Facebook
and all these companies and they've all
come together with their tens of billions
of dollars of collective purchasing
power to say,
we want transparency for manufacturers,
we want to know what's in products,
and then we're going to come together
and buy safer products with less toxics.
And that's really exciting.
I know I've just spoke at Harvard earlier
today in Harvard says they want to
organize a buyer's club here in the
northeast and see if they can get MIT and
other educational institutions.
Um,
Oberlin's talking about trying to organize
one in the Midwest with a lot of the
small schools there.
So buyer's clubs can be really powerful
and can really move the market. Uh,
yeah. Here's Harvard saying they want
to make a buyer's club targeting harmful
chemicals on campus.
So we're going to talk now
about flame retardants.
That's how I started doing all this.
And the reason they're there is back
in the 70s standards were made for
products, children's sleepwear, furniture,
foam, plastic building, insulation.
And these standards led to
the use of flame retardants.
And nobody asked if the standards provided
a fire safety benefit or asked about
the harm of the chemicals.
And with flame retardancy only way to
change things is to change standards.
Changing the chemicals doesn't work.
There's always a chemical cousin.
But if the standards change,
then you no longer need them.
So back to people's couches.
Several of you bought your couches
bef between 2005 and 2012 and you have
chlorinated Tris, the same chemical
that was removed from kids pajamas.
And the reason is a California standard
called technical bulletin one one seven.
If you go home, you lift the
center Christian of your couch,
you'll probably see a label that says
[inaudible] seven and this is not a very
effective standard.
It requires the foam inside the furniture
to resist a very small flame for 12
seconds.
And so if you think about that,
what happens if you drop a candle
on your couch? What Burns first,
the fabric.
And when the fabric burns,
you have a large flame and then the
foam burns and two or three seconds.
And when foe, when foam has is treated
with flame retardants and it burns,
it gives off a lot more
smoke and toxic gases.
And what kills people in fires is such
smoke and toxic gases and so technical
and,
and one,
one seven has been around since 1975
and there's no data to show that it's
provided any fire safety,
but it is instead ended up that the
toxic flame retardant chemicals are,
and most Americans bodies the chemical.
So if you brought your couch before 2004,
anybody have a couch from before?
2004.
Okay,
well those who are worse because they
all have a very harmful chemical.
Um,
the pent up,
it's pent up brominated
[inaudible] ether a big mouthful,
but the top picture up there
is polybrominated by fennel,
a PBB or a PCB.
Those are toxic.
They're persistent. Pcbs, you know,
are not good molecules. If you,
instead of having a covalent bond,
you have an ether bond between your rings,
then you have a polybrominated
by fennel ether.
And if you burn or oxidize,
that becomes another ether bond.
This is a dioxin and a few man.
So this is the flame retardant that was
used from 1975 until 2004 to meet to be
one,
one seven.
It's happily instructure between the
Dayaks and between the dioxin and a PCB.
Not a great molecule to have in your
home, in your dust, in your body.
And in fact,
we had a group of Berkeley students,
summer students studying chemistry
and policy at Berkeley collecting foam
samples and getting them analyzed.
And one of the professors said that the
students should not touch that PBD flame
retardant except wearing full gear
and a fume hood. And I'm like,
but it's in everybody's furniture.
So that is an unfortunate thing.
Um,
and almost all the use of the chemical
has been in North America in large part
to meet this standard, but it has
traveled the world as a global pollutant.
So when we make these sorts of
chemicals, they go all over. Um,
there are hundreds of animal studies
showing a neurological and reproductive
harm from the Penta chemical.
And about two weeks ago,
studies were finalized showing it
indeed does cause cancer in humans.
If pregnant women have higher levels,
it takes them longer to become pregnant.
Um,
and during critical windows
of brain development,
their thyroid hormones are altered so
that their children will have lower birth
weight, impaired attention, uh,
poor coordination and lowered Iq.
So the average California Chubb has lost
four to five Iq points just from this
flame retardant Penta and economist
calculated and $9 billion loss in earning
power in California children
due to Iq loss from Penta,
which is one of the many,
many harms from this chemical.
So how does the chemical end up in us?
Um,
it's a semi volatile
organic chemical and SVOC.
So it's continually coming out
of furniture, dropping into dust.
And if you say eat a sandwich,
you have some dust on your fingers,
you eat a little bit of dust, the
Penta ends up inside of you. Um,
children,
toddlers who chrome,
the dust put their hands in their mass
tend to have three to five times higher
levels than their parents,
which is not a good thing.
And cats have up to a hundred times
higher level compared to humans.
Why would cats have such a high level
because of their grooming behavior?
So as I said, no fire safety
benefits, serious harm,
uh, we came to realize
that TB one, one seven,
the standard could be changed to a
fabric standard that could be met without
flame retardants that would
stop the fire in the fabric.
So they didn't need to be any flame
retardants and you could have increased by
your safety. Does that sound
like a good idea? So we had, uh,
a bill with Senator Mark Leno there in
front and our bill was supported by the
furniture industry who didn't like
putting toxics in their furniture,
foam industry fabric industry.
Firefighters supported it because they
knew the flame retardants didn't help and
could cause cancer.
Everybody supported it,
but these bills never passed.
And the reason was Californians
for fire safety and they,
this is part of a one week long $7 million
advertising campaign when one of the
bills almost passed and they
were very determined, I believe,
to keep their market share
and selling flame retardants.
And the legislators tended
to vote for California.
It's for fire safety rather
than business firefighters,
scientists and the public.
And this went on for about six years and
I go to hearings where the lobbyist for
the flame retardant
industry would be saying,
it's not sound science to say there's
harm from any flame retardants.
They've all been evaluated by the
EPA evaluated. What did they find?
They don't say that part.
So we decided to put together all the
science and in a big meeting in San
Antonio,
we developed the San Antonio Statement.
It was signed by a couple
of hundred scientists.
It documented the harm and the lack
of benefit of the flame retardants.
And it was published in environmental
health perspectives back in 2010 and still
nothing much happened. Um,
I would sort of joke, I,
when I went to parties,
people would ask me what I did and I'd
start telling the whole story of the
toxic flame retardants and
everybody's furniture, no benefit,
and get all wound up. And after a
while they'd go, I have to leave now.
And I'd see them on the other side
of the room talking to someone else.
And I thought,
oh my goodness,
am I going to spend my whole life being
this woman who rants at parties about
filing returns? You know, Stonyfield
just a little crack powder ish.
And then things changed
when the Chicago Tribune,
I had pitched this to many,
many reporters,
but the Chicago Tribune
did a fantastic job. Uh,
this is the first front page,
the headline,
a deceptive campaign by industry,
but flame retardants into our homes and
into our bodies and the chemicals didn't
even work as promised.
And this story documents,
it's kind of what I'd been,
all these hearings I had been to,
there was awfully sis burn doctor who'd
won the Dalai Lama compassion award.
And he was always talking
about some poor burned baby.
It was this horrific death,
this baby at all because there were no
flame returns in her crib and it was
horrible.
And it never really connected to what
the subject of the legislation was.
It made no sense.
But he would do it and then everybody
would be very emotional and it would give
the legislators sort of covered to vote
no on these new standards that would
increase by her safety.
And so these reporters kind of research
the hearings and they listened to four
times. He talked about the burn baby and
they realized they were all different.
And then they confronted him
and he said, well, really?
I was just kind of talking.
Um,
but there was a baby and he gave them
a picture of a baby and they tracked it
down and this baby died for a
completely different reason.
And the mother was really unhappy.
And the doctor said,
well, we're not under oath in
California so I can say what I want.
And ultimately it was learned that he was
paid $240,000 for his testimony and he
stopped being a doctor. So,
but real scandal, you know,
in the series, if you want to read
them, you can read playing with fire.
They came in second for the Pulitzer.
They won all these environmental
awards and everything changed.
So instead of me being this person,
but parties ranting,
suddenly Dick Durbin was
ranting in the Senate. Uh,
there were hearings in the Senate.
Um,
this really empowered Jerry Brown,
our governor.
That series came out in May,
2012 a month later,
Jerry Brown directed the state agencies
to revise our standards so that we could
reduce and eliminate
dangerous flame returns.
And at the same time increase fire safety.
So
this made a huge difference.
And thanks to this, uh,
we now have a new standard.
You can go out and buy a couch
that meets TB one one seven, 2013.
Um,
and as you see your couch,
we'll have a label on it and it says
either contains flame returns or contains
no flame retardants. So you,
you can have that choice.
Um, foam, plastic building
insulation. Unfortunately,
the materials that make buildings
energy efficient, polystyrene, poly,
urethane and puff,
probably ISO Cyani rate contain the
worst flame retardants and there's no
benefit.
You think about foam below the
cement below the grade down there,
it has flame retardants,
there's no oxygen,
there is no fuel source and nonetheless
flame retardants are required.
So we are now and it's really hard
been trying to change the international
building code to allow foam plastic
without flame retardants where there is no
fire safety benefit. The big
hearing is September 30th. Um,
and it's really a struggle because the
same three companies who make the flame
retardants are adamantly wanting to
keep them in our building installation.
Um, if you want to reduce your
own flame retardant exposure, uh,
it's not a bad time to buy new furniture
or to swap out the foam in your
furniture for safer from or else
to vacuum with a hepa filter,
wet mop and hand wash.
It all reduces exposure to dust.
Um, so I'm going to go now through the
rest of the classes much more quickly.
A highly fluorinated chemicals I
think are the worst of the worst.
The carbon fluorine bond is the
strongest in the periodic table.
Um, it really does not
break for geologic time.
So this class of chemicals are
very oil and water repellent,
but they never break down.
They just accumulate on the planet.
And the chemical that was mostly used
was something called the Pfoa or c eight,
eight carbons surrounded by fluorines.
And this is a book stain resistant
nonstick, waterproof and lethal,
the hidden dangers of ca.
And it's very interesting because it
tells the story of the harm of c eight and
a story that what happened was [inaudible]
was used in the making of tough fun.
Um,
dupont dumped the ca in the water
supplies and communities in Ohio and West
Virginia. Uh, people got sick, they sued,
they measured the levels in thousands
of people who had very high level.
And then they looked at health effects.
And among those people, this is again,
human health effects. They found
higher levels of two kinds of cancer,
cholesterol, thyroid disease,
all those health conditions.
And those people sued dupont.
And the first hearing is today.
So this happened a long time ago.
Today is the first lawsuit I read about
it and dupont had known since the 60s
about the harm of c eight.
They had been monitoring the water supply,
knew it was in the water,
but they claimed that the levels they
didn't think were that high and they said,
and if the chemical had
really been harmful,
but government would have regulated
it, that was their argument. So,
um,
we'll see what happens with these trials.
But dupont is actually spun
off all this liability.
They have a new company called Kenmore's
that has the liability and makes these
chemicals. So it's not clear
what the outcome will be,
but you can follow it online.
Where are these chemicals found?
Food contact paper.
If paper is oil and grease resistant,
like pizza boxes,
microwave popcorn bags,
it very likely has highly
fluorinated chemicals. Cosmetics,
not many cosmetics,
but several thousand of them do
contain fluorinated chemicals.
It will say flouro on the package.
Outdoor equipment,
carpets, clothing, furniture. Um,
and so c eight has been
phased out in 2015.
It took 50 years from when
the harm was first discovered.
And what is the replacement for ca
[inaudible] six carbons with fluorines all
around.
It's equally persistent.
It doesn't break down for geologic time.
That's millions of years,
possibly longer than humanity.
And the world is like filling up with
it and there's nowhere for it to go.
It's in water, increasing
levels in human blood. Um,
still at ground to Shane, a professor
at Harvard who studies it says,
it seems to accumulate in the brain and
do we really want see a in our brains?
Um, so we did a Madrid statement
on highly fluorinated chemicals. I,
it was signed by 230 scientists published
last May 1st and environmental health
perspectives. Nobody much had
heard about these chemicals. They,
I always say did not get the
attention they had deserved.
So we document the potential for harm,
a roadmap to prevent further harm.
And it got a lot of press.
Nick Christoff wrote about chemicals
in your popcorn, national geographic,
these chemicals and pizza boxes
and carpeting last forever.
My favorite massive group of scientist
thinks you shouldn't use nonstick from
modern farmer,
but there were hundreds of press hits
and the world is slowly starting to find
out about nonstick.
Um,
a lot of brands are eliminating it.
Starting with h and m
Levi's has phased it out.
Now these brands don't talk about it
because if, you know, if they say, well,
you're, you know, your new products
don't have this toxic chemical,
what does that say about your old products
so that they don't tend to advertise
it,
but it is happening.
This is in the public domain that all
these companies are facing it out. Um,
what can be done?
Um,
Google really wants safe building for
their employees and they're very active
and working for transparency and
they're part of the buyer's club.
And we're working with the buyers club
in California to give them lists of
products with and without
fluorinated chemicals.
This is from a database called Pharos,
but there's a lot more chemicals in this.
So if you want any of these products,
you can pick the ones with and
without the fluorinated chemicals.
And the hope is to really move
the market towards without,
when people know the extent of the harm.
And the fact like with every,
you know,
the chemical industry is saying
a c six is perfectly fine,
but they're 40 forms of c six,
we took 50 years to ban one form
of [inaudible] band phase out.
So with 40 forms of c six,
it's just not going to happen.
But purchasers can move to safer products.
So all of these products can
contain fluorinated chemicals.
So try not to buy nonstick
and if you can avoid it.
Um,
the last class I'm going to talk about
in some detail is the chlorinated
antimicrobials.
That's Tyco San and try called carbon.
They're used, for
example, in liquid soaps.
It turns out the best thing to
wash your hands is soap and water.
You really having bacteria on
your hands is a good thing. Um,
triclose and kills all the bacteria.
I've heard people say, well,
maybe in a hospital setting it's useful,
but Kaiser has banded about six years ago.
Um,
now that's pure al. You
know, alcohol is fine.
It's try close and the antimicrobial
try called carbon and it's really sad.
But the FDA back, you can
see, get that pointer.
In 1974,
the FDA wrote a monograph on the lack
of efficacy and safety of Trico sand and
that report's still has not been
finalized and published. Meanwhile,
back in 94,
there was a handful of
uses for antimicrobials
because they were considered
pharmaceuticals and they were
removed from that category.
And now there's 2000 uses.
So antimicrobials,
microbiome,
Tracko centric,
oh carbon or no fast number
of products and building.
They're in everything, you know,
doorknobs, counters, seals, walls.
But the fact is they don't
provide a benefit. They have
huge potential for harm.
They reach out of products, they're not
taken out by sewage treatment plants.
So they end up in our water supply there.
One of the top 10 water contaminants,
they'd been found to be
an endocrine disruptor.
And tragically there in
most women's breast milk,
which is not where you want these
chemicals. And the fact is, once again,
we don't need them. They're
not needed. And so again,
purchasers can pick products without um,
Tracko San and try called carbon.
And Google is really leading the
way in these kinds of efforts.
Consumer products, um,
cosmetics because um,
trackless San is actually considered
a pesticide. It has to be labeled.
And so when you buy things,
you can look Colgate total
toothpaste 0.05% triclose San,
uh, I heard crest is advertising that
it doesn't contain, tried go San.
So that's a good sign. But when
you're buying personal care products,
you can just look on the label
cleaning products, apparel,
all these products you can
choose with and without Tyco sin
so quickly. The other classes
I won't go into in much detail,
bespoke phenols many of you probably
go out of your way to get water bottles
that say this fennel a free,
anybody do that?
So I have a friend who studies them as
toxicologists that UC Davis who likes to
shock people.
So he goes around saying,
I really liked my water bottle to say
it's got this fennel a in it because that
way I know that doesn't have this funnel
s in it and that the substitute for bis
fennel a is often bis fennel
s which he thinks is worse.
So with the class concept,
we don't want bisphenol a to z.
Do you really need something like
this panel? Do you need that function?
Is it worth it? Is it necessary?
And if it's worth it and necessary,
then let's really invest
in Green Chemistry and come
up with something entirely
different that meets this function
without that potential for toxicity.
Similarly,
thalates that also helps soften plastics.
There's a tendency to go from one
harmful thal eight to the next.
So let's find green chemistry solutions
when we need it. And in many cases,
let's not use it.
Solvents hydrocarbon coronated
oxygenated solvent's often are harmful.
Many times you can use water.
One way to reduce your own
exposure is to limit dry cleaning.
And when you bring things back from
the dry cleaners to air them out,
there's aqueous dry cleaning so
you can use water instead. Um,
and you can find aqueous dry cleaners.
Well,
we can own for a long time
about the harm of these metals.
And still there's paints
with letting them,
it's still worth checking,
reducing the levels.
So what's happening, uh,
retailers are changing.
Many are selling furniture without
flame retardants, a home depot,
Lowe's and Menards or phasing
out validates and flooring. Um,
I got an email near the middle,
middle of June that made me really
happy from a major us retailer,
but I can't mention their name.
People don't like dimension and they
said starting July 1st we're not selling
anything with flame retardants
or stain repellents.
We're not offering any
stain repellent treatments.
And this is a loss of a profit center
for us because we make money with these
stain repellent treatments,
but it's the right thing to do.
So if you go to and try to get a stain
repellent treatment and they won't sell
it to you, you'll know
this is the retailer. Um,
Akia is really the star this year,
a Kia who we've been working
with for quite a while and said,
no fluorinated chemicals in
any of our products worldwide.
There are substitutes,
they said for shower curtains,
raincoats and umbrellas,
but that they have a nice tablecloth
that needs grease resistance that doesn't
exist without fluorinated chemicals.
So they're going to stop
selling the tablecloth,
which is pretty principled
and pretty neat. So, um,
and a Kia has banned chemicals
and all of the six classes.
So based on all that, we have come
up with a very bold statement.
We believe that the youth of some or all
of the six classes containing chemicals
of concern can be reduced in consumer
products by 50% in five years.
And I think that's possible. Just asking
the, do you need it? Question. You know,
a Kia has done this.
One large American retailers has done it.
Um, we're having a meeting in
December with the furniture,
commercial furniture industry,
the big companies,
and they're interested in stopping
the use of all antimicrobials,
flame retardants and stain
repellents in office furniture.
That is a big deal. And if they do,
that's going to really reduce the use.
So I'm really optimistic.
Um,
our goal is to take good science
and use it for good policy.
And now I'm saying you can use good
science for good purchasing and the
purchasing can be even
more powerful than policy.
So we send out newsletters once a
month with updates on all of this.
If you'd like to be on our
newsletter list in the back there,
please leave your card or sign your name.
Um,
give me your card.
Uh,
and I'm happy to autograph books if you'd
like a copy of an printer or breaking
trail out there, both here. Um,
so I'm optimistic that by reducing
the use of harmful chemical classes,
we can all have a healthier world.
So thank you.
Yeah.
So if there are any questions,
please come to the mix.
Hi. Thank you. Um,
so if I go to whole foods and I go to the
cleaning aisle and they have all these
things that say they're safe and green,
are they,
I kind of looked for trackless San,
I don't know pop. They're probably,
but I think it's good to take a
quick scan of the ingredients.
Hi. Um, I have a question about
the a, the c six in the Ca,
the chemicals that don't break
down and geological time.
Does that also make them less reactive?
So would they be less likely to cause
harm and biological? Um, you know,
chemical reactions
because that would be nice. No, right.
Unfortunately they appear to cause a
lot of harm and the mechanisms aren't so
well knowing
well they might be like
catalyst or something.
Yeah. Are they fit in? They
fit into, we don't know why,
but there's this unique human epi
study of these, I think, I don't know,
20,000 people who've been exposed,
um,
in southern Ohio and West Virginia where
they came up with that whole list of
health problems that's on the slide.
And in fact,
that's what the lawsuit
today are starting.
So it's pretty unusual to have
that much human, you know,
cause all these chemicals, by
the way, to say the six classes,
the harm is irrefutable.
You know,
there are things like genetically modified
foods are real worried but there's
not a lot of data to show him these.
What we went for is what we,
the things where there
was no question of harm.
We didn't have to do any more experiments.
So the fluorinated chemicals
that have been studied,
there's vast numbers of animal studies
and then inadvertently the very sad quote
human studies where human populations
are exposed and you find human health
problems.
So I think the harm from ca
is knowing from c six there,
40 kinds. It's going to be
really hard to prove things.
I mean the fact that it ends up in the
brain is not a good sign and they are
biologically active.
Okay.
Well I do hope that you
will sign our mailing list.
You can go to green science policy.org
and click on fluorinated chemicals and
learn more or click on six classes
and learn about the six classes.
And, um, if I said,
if you sign our mailing list
or you can send me an email
arlene@greensciencepolicy.org and we'll
write you once a month and update you on
what's happening.
I think saying in five years we're going
to reduce the use of these chemicals by
50% in consumer products is a high goal.
But it feels to me just like Annapurna,
you know,
that seemed pretty impossible.
One of the world's highest mountain that
had never been climbed by a woman or an
American that,
you know,
we were able to get a team together
and reach the summit of Annapurna.
And so to me, this feels just
the same, um, a great team.
If you sign our mailing list, you'll
be part of the team, you know,
working with scientists,
people in industry,
government and NGOs and we
all see the same summit.
It's a healthier world. And I think,
you know, moving step by step,
we can all achieve that goal.
So thank you.
Okay.